- So welcome everyone to the
Asian American Cultural Center
and the Asian-American lecture series.
It's really wonderful to
have so many of you here
on a Thursday afternoon.
I know there's a lot going on
so we're all very grateful
for your presence today.
So first, of course, I wanna thank the
Center for Race, Indigeneity,
and Transnational Migration
for supporting this
wonderful lecture series
and I'm just really thrilled
to be bringing back two of our alumni
from the Yale American Studies program,
Professors Simeon Man and Elizabeth Son.
So I'm gonna give quick
introductions to the two of them
and then I'm gonna turn it over
to hear about their wonderful work.
So Professor Man is an
assistant professor of history
at the University of
California at San Diego.
He's an affiliate faculty member
of the department of ethnic studies
and the program in
critical gender studies.
He specializes in Asian American history
and transnational US history
with a focus on the politics
of race and Empire.
He received his PhD in American
Studies at Yale in 2012
and graduated from the
University of Washington
where he received his BA.
And before joining the
faculty at UC San Diego,
he was an Andrew W Mellon
Postdoctoral fellow
at Northwestern from 2012 to 2014
and also a provost postdoctoral
scholar in the humanities
at the University of Southern California
and that was from 2014 to 2015.
So we're gonna be hearing
about his first book,
Soldiering Through Empire:
Race and the Making of
the Decolonizing Pacific
which just came out
from the University of
California Press last year, 2018.
It's a cultural history
of the US military in Asia
and Pacific after World War
II and the book explains
how the United States
mobilized citizens from nations
and territories throughout the region
for the US war in Vietnam.
And particularly, the
work really reconsiders
this question of soldiering as labor,
as military labor, civilian
labor, forms of labor
that's critical to the expansion
of the American Empire post-war.
Professor Elizabeth Son will
be following Simeon Man.
And she's an associate
professor, recently tenured,
at Northwestern University.
(audience applause)
She completed her American Studies PhD
a year before professor Man, in 2011,
so she has courtesy appointment...
Oh sorry, she's associate
professor of theater
at Northwestern University.
She holds courtesy appointments
in the Department of Performance Studies,
Asian-American Studies and the
program in American Studies.
She's an interdisciplinary
scholar whose research focuses
on the interplay between
histories of gender-based violence
and contemporary performance
in the United States
and South Korea.
Her book, which we'll be hearing from,
Embodied Reckonings:
"Comfort Women," Performance,
and Transpacific Redress
is from the University of
Michigan Press, also 2018
and examines the political
and cultural aspects
of contemporary
performances in South Korea,
Japan and the United States
that have grappled with the history
of Japanese military sexual slavery.
Her scholarly articles have appeared
in Asian Theatre Journal,
Theatre Survey, Theater
and many others, and she's
also a public scholar.
She writes off ads which have
appeared in such publications
as the Los Angeles Review
of Books and The Hill.
Both scholars have garnered awards
for their amazing
groundbreaking scholarship
and we're delighted to have
them back on campus today.
So please join me in welcoming them
and the first to speak is Professor Man.
(audience applause)
- So thank you so much
Mary and thank you everyone
for being here.
It's really, really wonderful
to be back in the space.
This is where the project got started,
being in conversation with
so many people and my cohort,
in our seminars and I think
it's really interesting
that even though we each have
our own very individual
projects, I think we all,
we're grappling with some
broad similar questions,
questions that were
percolating in American Studies
at the time about the limits of liberalism
and its promise of
freedom through inclusion
and ways of reckoning
with histories of violence
and it's long persistent aftermaths.
So Soldiering Through Empire
which I'm gonna talk
about today really grew
out of these conversations.
It is an attempt to
wrestle with what I see
as one of the central paradoxes
of post-1945 US-Imperial culture,
that is how did the United
States legitimate itself
as a champion of racial
equality and democracy
and yet, at the same time,
expanded state powers
to wage war throughout
the decolonizing world?
How do we reconcile the
seeming contradiction
between these dueling
imperatives of liberal inclusion
and racialized state violence?
So I approached this question
by turning to the military
and exploring the ways that Asian soldiers
were mobilized for US military projects
in Asia and the Pacific,
especially during the Vietnam War.
In one sense, the book is
an attempt to tell a history
of the International Vietnam war beyond
an area studies framework
of Cold War history
and to think instead about
the legacies of colonialism
in Asia and the Pacific and
how they continue to manifest
through the militarized
labor of their citizens.
And I look at three specific sites;
the Philippines, South Korea and Hawaii.
In these countries and
territories after World War II,
we see a similar pattern
of colonial subjects
being liberated from colonialism
to take part in US war.
This process of ushering
freedom through violence
was at the heart of US
imperialism after 1945
and I call this process the making
of the decolonizing Pacific.
The decolonizing Pacific is
not so much a fixed geography
but rather names a historical conjuncture
in which the unfinished struggles
for decolonization throughout
Asia and the Pacific
became intertwined with and
co-opted by the US imperative
of securing the global capitalist economy.
Asia for Asians as a
discourse and a practice
was the US response to
the emerging third-world.
It was an attempt to pacify
anti-colonial resistance
and to channel the freedom
dreams of the formerly colonized
into the economy of war making.
So viewed through this lens
of the decolonizing Pacific,
the involvements of different
nations and territories
in the Vietnam War tells us a larger story
than the International Vietnam War.
Instead, it reveals that
the war was the very ground
on which the struggles
were an unfulfilled freedom
from colonialism would be waged,
contained and radicalized.
To tell this trans-pacific
history of soldiering,
I turn to the military
and examined the kinds
of social relations that have facilitated
among racialized subjects of US Empire.
In describing the post-1945 US empire,
scholars have used phrases
like empire of bases,
archipelago of empire.
As useful as these are
in helping us comprehend
the extensive global
reach of the US military,
for the most part, they
have actually limited us
in fully understanding
how the military works.
So in my accounts, the
military is more than just
a transparent essence for the US Empire
whose power is seemingly self-explanatory
by pointing to its size,
permanence or hidden nature.
Instead, I approach the military
as a site of contingency
where state power operates
in far more intricate ways,
blurring the boundaries between
inclusion and exclusion,
violence and benevolence,
peacetime and wartime.
In Asian-American
Studies, the military also
has been treated in somewhat
one-dimensional terms
as an institution that has served
to incorporate ethnic
minorities into the nation.
This myopic view has
reproduced liberal narratives
of race and citizenship, of the transition
from racial exclusion
to national inclusion
with World War II marking
the turning points.
So my examination of
Asian-American racial formation
through a trans-pacific lens,
specifically through the history
of Asians being conscripted
to work the US military
Empire, there's an attempt
to disrupt this narrative.
So my argument is this, that
Asian-American citizenship
has a genealogy in US Imperial violence.
Their inclusion into the
nation was predicated
on their mobilization
to police new boundaries
of exclusion elsewhere in
the decolonizing world.
So that's the crux of the larger projects
and what I'm gonna do now is
to dive into parts of the book
to give you a sense of that archives.
One of the early participants
of the US war in Vietnam
was this group of Filipinos mobilized
under the name Operation Brotherhood.
They were doctors and
nurses who had received
their medical training in
US colonial institutions
and whose skills and
desires would get channeled
into the service of the
post-world War II US empire.
The first contingent shown
here arrived in South Vietnam
in the fall of 1954,
soon after the collapse
of French colonial rule
and the Geneva Accords
divided the country.
Specifically, they were
mobilized by the CIA
as an experiment in psychological warfare.
Their task was to win the
trust of the Vietnamese people
and to steer them closer
to the South Vietnamese governments.
The CIA refer to them
in racializing terms.
They saw them as
quote-unquote, free Asians
who could demonstrate to the Vietnamese;
quote, from one brown-skin to another
what it meant to embody liberal democracy.
If the Philippines was the show
window of American democracy
as they were popularly known at the time
in Asia, during the cold war,
the Filipinos of Operation
Brotherhood helped convey
that idea through counterinsurgency.
Wait, so here is an image
of Dr. Antonio Velasco
with this first contingent and this is
actually the kinds of images
that the CIA wanted to project
of Asians helping Asians,
with Americans receding
in the background or at most,
taking a secondary role.
So to Americans, Operation
Brotherhood was a means
to an end of winning and
securing the population.
The actual medical remedy
they provided the Vietnamese
was in many ways inconsequential
and they actually openly
admitted that in their reports.
One report written by
Edward Lansdale is revealing
in the sense.
So in the report, he noted that
besides their medical work,
the Filipinos also performed
a kind of social intimacy
with the Vietnamese that was crucial
to the counterinsurgency.
Quote, they made up their own songs,
they held parties in off-duty
hours and in general,
were a real tonic to the dispirited.
Even the presence of pretty
Filipino girl doctors
was enough to encourage
Vietnamese to learn English
so they could talk to them, end quote.
So there's a picture of Edward Lansdale
being kind of creepy, just
standing in the background.
So Edward Lansdale figures quite centrally
in most historical accounts
of the Philippines-Vietnam connection
because he was the one who was credited
with perfecting counterinsurgency
tactics in the Philippines
and then exporting it to South Vietnam.
Historians have rightly argued
that we need to move away
from Lansdale because he has a tendency
of over-emphasizing his own
influence but at the same time,
we turned to his papers and his archives
because I think his documents reveal
what I'm calling the intimacies
of counterinsurgency,
these kinds of social relations
that are otherwise occluded
if we only focus on
military state documents.
So one of the nurses, Josefina Pablo,
recalled in an interview.
She said, "The Vietnamese trusted us
"and accepted us very well."
And it was this trust that
made it possible for her
to teach them about public health.
Josefina was 25 years old when she arrived
in South Vietnam in 1955.
She was a recent graduate
of St. Luke's Hospital School of Nursing
which was established by Americans
during the colonial period.
Josefina saw Operation Brotherhood
as fulfilling her desire
to quote, travel and see the world
and to put to good use her nursing degree.
She had no expectations
of securing South Vietnam
from communism, that figured
far in the back of her mind.
Instead, she simply
considered her medical deeds
on behalf of the Vietnamese
her most lasting accomplishments.
So this is the point
that I wanna emphasize,
although these Filipinos
traveled to South Vietnam
as educated subjects of the US Empire,
just as Americans had
intended, their interactions
with the Vietnamese, at times, testified
to a colonial intimacy
of a different kind,
an affection that refused
to be instrumentalized
and that at least momentarily
signaled something else beyond
the counterinsurgency imperative.
At the same time, that
it's important to recognize
that their desires became channeled
into the work of counterinsurgency.
We also need to recognize
that the US project
of securing Asia for
Asians sowed the seeds
of its own unraveling as we'll
see in a different example.
So I'm gonna turn now
to, briefly, to Hawaii
because in Hawaii, we
also see the entanglements
of liberalism and state violence at work
but also the challenge posed by anti-war
and anti colonial resistance.
Like Philippine-Independence,
Hawaii statehood in 1959
was hailed as a gift to
freedom demonstrating
the US commitment to liberal democracy
and similar to how
Filipinos were recruited
to extend that gift to the Vietnamese,
discourses of Hawaii's
statehoods were mobilized
in the service of war.
In 1965, the 25th Division
known as Hawaii's Own deployed
from Schofield Barracks in
Oahu to Cu Chi districts
in South Vietnam.
Its mission was standard
counterinsurgency,
soldiers built schools and hospitals.
They launched public health campaigns
and generally sought to
convey their good intentions
to the people.
As part of their operation,
the soldiers collected
donations from Hawaii citizens
to give to the Vietnamese.
The operation was called Helping Hand
and the entire spectacle
was replete with references
to Hawaii statehood.
The commanding general
called it an extension
of our aloha to the people of Vietnam
and like Operation Brotherhood,
Operation Helping Hand
succeeded in large part
by enacting different stories
about different places,
folding one narrative into another.
If statehood was celebrated
as the liberal inclusion
of Hawaii into the US nation,
then that became the narrative frame
for the counterinsurgency
as the soldier sought to
incorporate the Vietnamese
into a vision of domesticity
that was predicated
on the ongoing dispossession
of Native Hawaiians
of their land and sovereigncy.
Such liberal enactments of war
could not ultimately contain
the war's brutal violence
and that violence was not the
result of counterinsurgency
gone awry but the logical
extension of liberal warfare.
So in the book, I discussed
some of these examples
of the kinds of racialized
training that took place in Oahu,
notably, so at Schofield Barracks,
they created a mock Vietnamese village
where soldiers trained and
I've uncovered a connection
between the soldiers who trained here
and the My Lai massacre
that took place in 1968.
So my point in making these connections
is not simply to draw a causal connection
but to make the broader argument
that liberal inclusion
produces the condition
for state violence and it's disavowal.
Racial liberalism was never
simply a cold war imperative
that occasionally gets forestalled by war.
Instead war was a terrain upon
which racial liberalism gained traction
in the post-World War II period.
So I'm gonna wrap up by
discussing just one more image.
So this image, a map of Oahu appeared in,
was published in an underground
anti-war GI publication,
called Liberated Barracks
based in Schofield Barracks.
It introduced a critical
reading of Oahu's geography,
mimicking a tourist
map and guiding readers
to the less familiar sites,
than what is presented
usually in a tourist brochure.
So in the top-left corner,
you can't really read it,
it says under scenic
points of interest stated,
be sure to visit all US military
occupied lands indicated
by blacked-out areas
And one of these blacked-out
areas was the My Lai,
what they called the My
Lai Jungle Training Center.
So pointing the reader's gaze
to the middle of the island,
the text revealed Hawaii's little Vietnam
as the genesis of the 1968 massacre.
The point of the map
was really quite simple,
to make transparent the
processes of militarization
that had gone hand in hand
with Hawaii's transformation
into a so-called paradise.
That these occurred in
lockstep was to justify
these final words at the bottom,
Paradise in the Pacific
for Genocide in Indochina.
This map represents the
kind of radical critiques
against the war and US Empire
that were emerging in Hawaii
during this period and on the one hand,
it would be easy for us
to interpret this activism
as a peripheral part of the
mainstream US anti-war movements
but if we expand our
view and situate our view
beyond the US framework,
it becomes apparent
that the struggles in
Hawaii were actually part
of the growing insurgencies
of the decolonizing Pacific.
In the Philippines, Okinawa,
Japan and elsewhere,
anti-military movements
were ascendant in the 1960s.
Base workers, American GIs,
labor and anti-war
organizers forged critical
and difficult alliances in
an effort to end the war
in Vietnam and their
governments complicity
with US imperialism.
These were all subjects of the US Empire
who were radicalized by
the war and struggled
for a different conception of freedom
that did not require their participation
in US state violence.
So I end the book with these accounts
of these trans-pacific movements
in order to show how US
militarism in Asia and the Pacific
and the broader US imperial projects
of securing an Asia for Asians
had the unintended consequence
of radicalizing the unfinished
struggles for decolonization
that were foreclosed.
I'll end there, thank you.
(audience applause)
- I wanna start off by thanking Mary
and the Center for the
Study of Race, Indigeneity
and Transnational Migration
for this invitation.
It's wonderful to share
the floor with Simeon,
to meet so many students working
in Asian-American Studies,
to see many of my teachers in the room
and to celebrate ER&M's 20th anniversary.
Almost 12 years ago,
when I began my research
on transnational activism
surrounding the history
of Japanese military sexual slavery,
I asked elderly Korean survivors
of wartime sexual violence
why they attended the
27-year-long weekly protests held
across from the Japanese
Embassy in Seoul, South Korea.
One woman, Kil-wa-nok
(speaks foreign language)
the word for grandmother in Korean,
explained that it was for the future.
As a living witness she believed
that it was her responsibility
to tell the world
about her experiences
and to fight for justice.
Kil-wa-nok was a teenager in 1940
when she was deceived
into becoming a sex slave
for Japanese troops in northeast China.
Like Kil-wa-nok, girl and young
women from Japan's colonies
and occupied territories
endured unspeakable violence
during their captivity in what
were essentially, rape camps.
These so-called comfort
stations could be found
throughout Japan's colonies
and occupied territories
in China, the Philippines, Southeast Asia
and the Pacific island.
For almost five decades,
personal and public silence
shrouded this history
until Korean survivors began
coming forward in the 1990s
and galvanized the then
nascent social movement
for redress.
Activists have pursued
political and legal redress
that has centered
on the Japanese
government's acknowledgment
of Japanese military sexual
slavery and official apology
and reparations.
Alongside the work of activists,
artists have been using
various cultural forms
from literature and visual
art to the performing arts
to engage with the history
of Japanese military sexual slavery.
To this day, the Japanese
government continues
to deny survivors full
reparative measures,
despite the agreement in 2015
between the governments
of South Korea and Japan
to try to quote, resolve,
end quote the issue.
In response to a long
history of state denials
and half-hearted apologetic innuendos,
a vibrant transnational
network of local activists
has organized throughout Asia,
Europe and the United States.
In my book, I show how
the official erasure
of wartime sexual crimes in which Japan
and the United States
participated after the war
and Japanese State denials
of official redress,
inadvertently nurtured
a transnational Asian/American
movement of activism
and artistic intervention.
I argue that performance
plays a central role
in how survivors, activists
and artists have grappled
with histories of sexual
violence and the erasures
of such experiences.
The history of Japanese
military sexual slavery,
a history that centered on the violation
of women's bodies calls for representing,
mobilizing and reinvesting those bodies
with meaning through redressive
acts such as protests,
tribunals, theater and memorial building.
The book builds on the work
of transnational
Asian-American Studies scholars
like Lisa Yoneyama and Cathy Schlund-Vials
in extending Lisa Lowe's
framework of the quote,
tireless reckoning, end quote
with America's imperial past
to trans-pacific cultural
practices of memory and justice.
In the case of the comfort women history,
this reckoning has to contend
with what Yoneyama calls the quote,
trans-pacific arrangement of
cold war justice, end quote.
Japanese state denials of
the comfort women history
tell only part of the
multinational silencing
of Japanese wartime criminality.
The United States is implicated
in official post-war
erasures of sexual war crimes
during the Tokyo war crimes trials,
inadequate post-war settlements
for Japanese war crimes
and involvement in the afterlife
of militarized sexual labor
and violence in Japan and South Korea
from 1945 to the present.
By focusing on live public enactments
and interactions between
performers and audiences,
I probe more deeply into
the embodied aspects
of remembrance and how
the everyday of activism
and artistic work can become
a sight a vibrant change
that confronts the amnesia
of transnational politics.
The public embodiment of
memory and its relation
to community formation
are important to my study.
The women's acts of
remembrance are central
to their public activism.
Communities of remembrance are
also sustained and nurtured
by the involvement of non-state actors
in activism, theater
and memorial building.
As Viet Nguyen writes; quote,
given the scale of so
many historical traumas,
it can only be the case
that for many survivors,
witnesses and inheritors,
the past can only be worked
through together, in
collectivity and community,
in struggle and solidarity, end quote.
Nguyen draws attention to the necessity
of a transgenerational
accounting of historical traumas
for many survivors,
witnesses and inheritors.
Communities of remembrance
may be disparate
in their identification,
politics and strategies
yet they are connected by
the actions of remembrance
in the pursuit of justice.
For the rest of my
talk, I'm going to focus
on the redressive potential of
memorial building by Koreans
and Korean-Americans in Seoul
and Glendale, California.
In recent years, as more of the
elderly survivors pass away,
activists are focusing on
memorialization efforts.
Stone and bronze
memorials to comfort women
can be found all over the world.
Locations range from Manila,
the Miyako Islands in Japan,
Palisades Park, New Jersey,
Glendale, California,
Toronto, Canada, Nanjing to Sydney.
Seoul is home to the
original bronze girl statue,
the most well-known comfort women memorial
and the majority of bronze girl statues
have been installed in
South Korean cities.
Outside of South Korea,
the largest concentration
of comfort women memorials
is in the United States.
Glendale is home to the
first bronze girl statue
outside of Korea.
And I'm interested in embodied engagements
with these memorials and what
these performances can tell us
about the interrelationship
between sexual violence,
memory, performance and
transnational politics.
These bronze girl memorials are examples
of what Robin Bernstein
calls scriptive things.
She writes, quote, a scriptive
thing like a play script,
broadly structures a performance
while allowing for agency
and unleashing original live variations
that may not be individually
predictable, end quote.
In the case of comfort women memorials,
as scriptive things, they
invite not just individual
but collective engagement
in the ethical work
of remembering histories
of sexual violence.
I look at memorials as scriptive things
that invite what I call
performances of care
or embodied acts that
materialize concern and interest
by providing for the needs of or looking
after what one is caring
for, in this case, memorials.
The materiality design
and location of memorials,
shape how they prompt or
invite behaviors of care
as scriptive things.
Dressed in a hanbok a
traditional Korean dress,
the realistically rendered
barefoot bronzed adolescent,
sits next to an empty bronze chair.
The bronze girl sits
stoically with clenched fists
and closed lips.
She stares straight ahead
at the Japanese embassy
in an accusatory manner,
though one could also read
a sense of peace and self
position in her stillness.
Her body language conveys
defiance and confidence.
Her head is held high
and her back is straight.
The statue's shadow is
laid out in a mosaic
of flat gray granite stones behind her
that outlines the silhouette
of a seated woman.
The bent back and bun of the
silhouette mark her as elderly.
The statue is located on
a sidewalk directly across
from the front gates of the
Japanese Embassy in Seoul
where the weekly Wednesday
demonstrations take place.
The location of the statue
allows multiple audiences
to view the statue; the Korean public,
the international public
and the Japanese state.
The artist who created the statue
and the South Korean
public colloquially refer
to the statue as the
(speaks foreign language)
or Girl Statue.
In naming her The Girl Statue,
supporters anthropomorphize the memorial.
They refer to the statue
as her and perform actions
of caring for it by dressing the statue
when it is cold or leaving gifts
and letters for the statue.
The act of sitting by the statue's side,
wrapping clothes around
it or leaving gifts,
literalizes keeping alive
the issue and memory
of these women while giving
people a chance to perform care
and to demonstrate their public support.
And this is a collage of on the top,
the different outfits of
the bronze girl statue
and in the lower right hand corner,
you'll see the statue
in different positions.
So these statues in various positions
are throughout South
Korea and it's fascinating
to see the ways in which the
public finds creative means
to care for the bronze girl.
The bronze girl statue's presence
has also rescripted the
Wednesday demonstrations.
In the summer of 2007,
when I first participated
in the protest, on average,
eight to 10 survivors
attended the demonstrations.
Last summer, when I attended
the Wednesday demonstration,
only one survivor was in attendance.
She sat not too far away
from the bronze girl statue,
which may soon be the only
survivor presence at the protest.
The bronze girl's statue, as an effigy,
as defined by Joseph Roach,
quote, fills by means
of segregation, a vacancy
created by the absence
of any original, end quote.
While also marking the impossibility
of completely filling that absence.
Moreover, the memorial as
scriptive thing invites
and reminds the public of
their role in remembering
the women in continuing their legacy.
The presence of the bronze girl
alongside the lone survivor,
powerfully highlights that we
are at a critical juncture.
There is an urgent need to transfer memory
to the next generation.
As part of that transmission of memory,
Korean-American communities
are increasingly turning
to memorial projects
as powerful redressive acts.
On July 30th, 2013 hundreds
of mostly Korean-Americans
and local non-Korean politicians
gathered in Central Park
in Glendale to unveil the
first comfort women memorial
built on public land on the
west coast of the United States.
Organizers of the Korean-American
forum of California
worked with Glendale City Council members
to build this memorial which was funded
by members of Korean-American communities
in the Los Angeles area.
Different Korean-American
Civic Organizations across
the states have taken up
the cause of comfort women
and installed memorials
in their communities.
While these memorials offer
the public an opportunity
to remember survivors and
their fight for justice,
they are also examples of how the appeal
of the comfort women issue
mobilizes political energy
for other causes in
Korean-American communities
such as building political alliances,
increasing a voter base or
expressing a group identity.
For many Korean-Americans,
commemorative practices
express a trans-pacific affinity
for the comfort women cause
that is truly rooted in a
belief in social justice.
Others see the memorials as a way
to express Korean nationalistic claims
or to assert their
identity as a US citizen.
The lines are not always
clearly demarcated
between these different and sometimes,
problematic motivations.
The dedication ceremony in Glendale
was a carefully orchestrated event
that helped frame the memorial
as a non-partisan issue
that cuts across national
and ethnic differences.
And I'm gonna focus on
one particular speaker.
Kathy Masaoka of Nikkei
for Civil Rights & Redress,
discussed her group's
10-year grassroots campaign
to win redress from the US
government for the internment
of Japanese-Americans during World War II.
Expressing her organization's support
for the comfort women survivors,
she voiced the importance of an apology
and reparations, "When
Japan sincerely apologizes
"and pays its reparations
to each of the comfort women
"before it's too late, it
will help these survivors heal
"and show that Japan has
learned from its past,"
said Masako.
Quote, she continues, "This
monument for the comfort women
"has also reminded all
of us that the abuse
"and trafficking of women
into forced prostitution
"or domestic slavery continues today
"even in this country."
She placed the Comfort Women Memorial
within the context of a larger discourse
on violence against women,
noting that it happens
even in this country.
Her comments raised an important question
about what is forgotten
when the experience
of comfort women are remembered,
through memorials like
the one in Glendale.
The plaque for the memorial
invokes the never again mantra
common to memorials, to mass violence.
Quote, and this is from the plaque,
it is our sincere hope that
these unconscionable violations
of human rights shall
never recur, end quote.
However, there is no
mention during the ceremony
of how these violations of human rights
might be occurring in the
sex trafficking of laborers
into the Los Angeles area or
in the sex interest industries,
near US military bases in Asia.
Perhaps these absences are invoked
in the empty chair situated on US soil.
As Lisa Yoneyama writes, quote,
the marked absence signified
by the empty chair
placed next to the statue
of the girl unsettled viewers
by reminding us other injuries
from state violence that
remain equally unseen
and unheard, end quote.
Survivor Kim-Bok-Dong speech
was the most powerful
performance I witnessed that day,
dressed in a hanbok
with a white (speaks foreing language) top
and black Chima skirt, she
was the living embodiment
of the bronze girl.
Her dress in the style and
color of young girls' outfits
during the time that she was
taken was both a reminder
of her age when she was
forced to become a sex slave
and a powerful gesture a
reclamation of that lost time.
Elegantly clad and speaking
in clear steady words,
she declared quote, as
I've been traveling,
I have saying that if
Japan does not come forward
and apologize then I
will go around the world
and build memorials, end quote.
Building a memorial is
both a call for redress
and an act of redress itself.
She continues to say,
"The memorial is representation
or the past history
"so I ask you to try
to protect and maintain
"the peace memorial here."
She invoked the language of protection
in extending an invitation
for others to join her
in her fight for justice.
She also articulated a
broad horizon of peace
that will ultimately be
for future generations.
The day after the dedication ceremony,
I met the O family.
They were from Riverside
and had driven to Glendale
to see the bronze girl statue
The son, a student at West
Point had come home for a visit
so the father decided that
it would be a good idea
for the family to see the statue together.
And this is a quote from the father.
It seemed like a good opportunity to talk
about Korean history.
When I asked him how he felt
after seeing the statue,
he responded, "Compared
to when I read about it
"in newspapers, seeing it
in person really moved it.
"Articles make it seem
like someone else's story
"but seeing the statue in person,
"makes it seem like my story."
I was struck by how the bronze girl statue
made the comfort women
history more relevant
and personal to Mr. O.
Perhaps it was the lifelike
design of the statue
as an adolescent girl
that resonated with him.
Mr. O son and daughter also seemed
to be moved by the experience.
The son spoke of how the
statue brought history
to life for him and made him feel
a deeper connection to home.
Quote, coming here and sitting
around the dinner table
and my parents telling me
stories about their past,
about their history, and coming out here,
brings it a lot closer to home, you know,
being able to visually see
what they're talking about, end quote.
Their sentiments were
similar to what people say
about leading survivors in person
or listening to their public testimonies.
The Glendale statue which is a replica
of the memorial in Korea is located
on an open green facing west
towards a group of tall trees.
The statue and the chair
are elevated five inches
off the ground on a stone block
that sits in the middle
of a gravel clearing.
The elevated position of the
memorial discourages people
from sitting in the
chair, unlike the statue
in Seoul, South Korea, across
from the Japanese embassy.
This likely also encourages
people to treat the memorial
like a shrine or grave.
So instead of sartorial
performances of care
which seem less necessary
in Southern California's warmer weather,
people in Glendale are more
likely to leave bouquets,
potted plants and flowers
and vases around the statue.
The comfort memorials
in Seoul and Glendale
are not simply objects
with static meanings.
As scriptive things, these
memorials invite behaviors
that illuminate the range of attachments
and feelings people have about
survivors and their cause.
Through sartorial and
horticultural performances of care,
individuals and communities
in Korea and the United States
demonstrate how survivors
have touched people's hearts
and motivated them to engage
with a difficult historical past.
Approaching Memorial
Building through the lens
of performance illuminates
the varied desires
of Korean and Korean Americans
that inform their commemorative practices.
Those who dress the bronze
girl, care for the women
who are sex slaves as young girls
and genuinely want to honor the memory.
Others see the memorials as
symbols of geopolitical issues
they are committed to fighting for.
Some see a Korea of
the past that they want
to protect the memory of.
And others, like the Japanese-American
activist in Glendale,
connect the memorials to a larger fight
to eradicate sex trafficking.
Through interactions with
memorials such as performances
of care, people become part
of trans-pacific communities
of remembrance.
They are commemorating not
only the wartime experiences
of survivors but also
their brave activism.
The act of sitting by the statues side,
wrapping clothes around
it or leaving gifts,
provide people with the
chance to participate
in something larger than themselves
and to share the comfort
women history with others
while honoring the women.
These performances of care
remind us of the vitality
of everyday acts of redress.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- [Lady] Thank you for
your beautiful books
and beautiful talks.
I was noticing how the
two of you were thinking
about trans-pacific as both
an imperial designation
but also a site of contestation
for alternative trans-pacific ties.
And I was wondering if
you would comment on that
and maybe think about the gendering
of the trans-pacific in the
ways you're both using them
in terms of soldiering on the one hand
and care on the other.
- I'm interested in thinking
about the trans-pacific
in a very specific moment,
of the post 1945 post-World
War II US projects in Asia
and using the Vietnam War
as a sight to think about the connections
of all of these different
countries and territories
that we otherwise don't
see the commonalities of.
So certainly, an imperial project
of trying to demonstrate how the US,
even though it's trying hard
to separate and distance itself
from the Japanese Empire of the past,
it's still very much using the rhetoric
of an Asia for Asians of the East Asia,
co-prosperity sphere but at the same time,
we do see that this is a project
that fails in many ways in
the sense, that it mobilizes
these unforeseen
alliances and interactions
among different racialized
colonial subjects,
not only about among
soldiers and civilians
but base workers.
So one thing that I don't
really dwell on in the book
but it's certainly a part of this making
of the decolonizing
Pacific is the alliances
that we see between anti-war,
anti-military activists
and sex workers at US
bases in the Philippines,
in Korea, in Okinawa and Japan.
So in that sense, I see the
gendering of the trans-pacific
is not only about creating it
like a masculinists project
that's rooted in the labor of soldiering
but it's also about how the military
is mobilizing different
gender in very different ways.
- And I'm thinking about the Pacific
both and is a political,
social and cultural space.
Thinking, first of all, in
terms of this trans-pacific
as an imperial project.
I followed though the
women and how in the years,
leading up to and during World War II,
if we track their movement
throughout the Pacific,
it's fascinating to see decades later
how the women, as activists,
we circulate along
those paths but as a way
to create a different kind of space,
a space of potentiality for reimagining
what redress looks like for the women.
Today I didn't get a chance
to really talk about,
in depth about theater
but what's fascinating
about theater productions
about the comfort women
is that many of them have a
transnational production history
so for example, there is a play,
the first Asian-American
play about the government
in the United States by Chummy Kim,
called comfort women was
picked up by a Korean director.
She had read a review in Korean
then contacted the playwright to translate
and to bring this play to Korea.
And it ended up having an
extended run throughout Korea
and what's fascinating is how this play
then also traveled from Korea to Canada.
So for me, it's fascinating to think about
not only the movements of the
women across different times
but also how cultural producers
are circulating between different spaces
to create a redressive arena
where people can re-engage with the issue.
- [Lady] Thank you.
- [Man] Thanks for these terrific papers,
really eye-opening and moving.
My question is about the Imperial move
into pre-existing structures in Indochina,
the French colonial structures,
in the case of post-world War II,
the movement of the United States military
into the structures created
by the Japanese military,
almost in some cases, if
I've read your work correctly
was a seamless transition in the way
in which that part of the history
activates a relationship of colonialism
with a deeper historical route
and I just wondered if you'd
care to comment on that.
- So in Japan, after
the end of World War II,
there were various sex industries
that were developed around military bases,
one particular place in Okinawa.
And what's interesting
about these structures
that were built earlier
is that some of the women
who were comfort women
during World War II,
many of them decided not to return back
to their home countries.
So some of them ended up
staying at some of these camps
and then serving US soldiers.
And what's fascinating
is that in my research,
I noticed that this
history has only come up
when people talk about this
tribunal that was held in 2000,
the women's international
war crimes tribunal
which was a people's tribunal organized
by various legal scholars and
women's advocacy organizations
around the world to bring together 64
comfort women survivors
to redress the feelings
of the Tokyo tribunal.
And what's fascinating is
that during that tribunal
and especially, there
was the main tribunal
and then there was a public hearing
on contemporary acts of
violence against women
is when they explicitly talked about
the ongoing militarized violence
against women in Okinawa
and it was during those presentations
that legal scholars and activists
were making these explicit connections
between these different
structures of violence
but it's interesting to
see how that history often
is submerged and not discussed
in these different arenas
of either theater or public testimony
or memorial building.
- So it's really interesting
to think about how the US
is actively disavowing
its imperial projects
and actively distancing itself
from Japanese and European imperial powers
before World War II, so one of the things
that I'm trying to do in
this book is to really show
the ways in which, contrary
to how Cold War histories
are narrated, that 1945 really
did not mark a drastic break
from the colonial, past
and the US post-colonial,
present or post-World War II period.
And one of the ways that
we see the continuation
the ongoing legacies
of Japanese imperialism
is in the desires of Korean subjects
to join the military, many of the recruits
who were recruited into
the Korean Constabulary
after World War II were
people who had previously
been trained or had been officers
in the Japanese Imperial Army.
So there's a continuation,
not only like in terms
of structures, structures of colonialism
but also in thinking about the desires
of colonial subjects themselves.
- [Lady] I have a
partially formed question.
Oh, I'm sorry, somebody
else have their hand missed.
No, I have a partially formed question
that I think brings the work back
into the United States proper in terms of,
because so much of the work
is out there in the Pacific
and we're tracing these different mappings
that the two of you are
bringing to the field
which are amazing but
I'm struck by Glendale
and Southern California
and I'm thinking about how is the work
that you're doing helping
us we rethink something
like Glendale.
Is there a way in which that we can,
as scholars in the field of
Asian-American studies need
to think about the local
in a very different way,
based on these mappings
that you're showing us.
So I feel like that's what
you're partially doing for us
and I wanted to hear a
little bit more about that.
- Let's see, where to begin?
(Simeon laughing)
I think, for me, what's interesting is
as a transnational Asian/American
performance scholar,
it's fascinating when I look
at a place like Glendale
because what I notice is
that I think to understand
the phenomena of Memorial
Building in Glendale, California,
I think we have to maybe
step back and think
about a larger temporal time span
because there's a way in
which the dedication ceremony,
as I mentioned was, of
course, highly scripted,
wanted to present this nonpartisan issue
that people across the
board were joining hands for
and wanting to support the women
but what's fascinating
is that the organization
behind the memorial was
also a number of individuals
who are at the forefront of
the efforts in the states
to pass HR 121 in the US
House of Representatives,
which was the first resolution
passed in the United States,
where the United States
called Japan to apologize
and to acknowledge what
happened to the women.
And what's fascinating about
that particular resolution
is that it was not only a coalition
of various Asian-American activists
and organizations across the country
but it was a transnational effort
that also where individuals
here in the States collaborated
with organizations in Korea to have some
of the survivors come and testify
before the US House of Representatives.
So I think that it's important to think
about the different histories behind
the actual culminating events of Glendale
but what's fascinating to me
is that I've been tracking
what's been happening in Glendale.
One of the fascinating things for me
is that and I don't understand
Southern California climate
but the bronze girl statue
is no longer bronze.
She's now become rusted and
almost has a greenish hinge
which is interesting and
it's just fascinating
how that space has not only become a place
where people come by and leave flowers
on particular anniversaries
but it's now become a space
for press conferences,
whenever there's like a big
issue like the 2015 deal
between the South Korean government
and the Japanese government
but it's also the space where
people will hold rituals
and funereal like services for survivors
who have passed away in Korea.
So it's fascinating how
that very localized space
of this park that's between
a senior citizens home
and a public library, if we
look at it through the lens
of performance, we get to see ways
in which the space has this history
that is connected not
only to ongoing politics
in the States to advocate for these women
but it's connected to
what's happening abroad.
And for me, it's fascinating
to think about rituals
and commemorating the women
long after they have passed away
in relation to the
ongoing quest for redress
for these women.
So that's my long
roundabout way of answering
your question about the ways in which
that very localized space,
it just has so many
fascinated sedimented meanings
for national politics
and the transnational politics of memory.
- It's really interesting you
brought up Kathy and myself
who was one of the speakers
because she also appears in my project
as an anti-war--
- Oh, get out!
- Activists in the 1960s.
So I guess to answer your question,
I see both Asian-American
GIs and veterans,
anti-war activists in Little
Tokyo in like wherever,
in the United States really making sense
of what was going on in
their local communities
through the language of US imperialism
and state violence in Vietnam.
I mean that's a familiar story and
the civil rights black power
Asian-American movements,
the ways in which state
violence overseas became
a way to really frame and
understand what was going on
with urban renewal, with policing.
But also I see
domestic space, foreign space as really
the boundaries of that,
being incredibly blurred
and we definitely see that
in the case of Hawaii,
where the militarized, racialized
training practices in Oahu
had a direct correlation
to the kinds of violence
in Vietnam.
We can also talk about Camp
Pendleton in Southern California
and the ways that again,
the racialized training practice is there
with the more recent wars,
had a direct relationship
with the state violence overseas.
So I see it's a different
way of making sense
of what we think of as domestic spaces,
that it's always tied to
Imperial projects elsewhere.
- [Lady] Hi, I have a
question for Professor Son.
I was really struck by your
reading of the empty chair
in the bronze girl memorial as potentially
an invitation to think about
solidarities and alliances
that could be forged between
the comfort women movement
and other sorts of
forms of state violence.
I'm thinking about the
comfort women memorial
that was recently
constructed in San Francisco
that has three women holding hands.
For those of you who are familiar,
a Korean woman, a Chinese woman
and I think a Filipino comfort woman
which is a different
sort of way of disrupting
that public memory.
So I would love to hear your thoughts
on the ways of these different forms
of sculptural commemoration
invite different kinds of
political possibilities that might exceed
as well as bring back into focus the issue
of comfort women because--
- So to my knowledge,
the San Francisco Comfort
Women Memorial, the trio,
is the only comfort women
memorial that materializes
this image of solidarity
and what's fascinating about
that particular memorial
is that it's located in Chinatown
but it's in St. Mary's
Park which is a public park
and it's fascinating to
see the coalition work
across ethnic boundaries
to make that particular
memorial fascinating
and when I visited last year,
what struck me about
that particular memorial
is the ways in which it
invites the pedestrian
to also move in this circular movement
because you're walking around and also,
most importantly looking up at the women
in a position of veneration
but what was fascinating
about the time when I visited
is that if you looked across and I forget
which direction it was
but across the street,
there's an art school and on the wall,
of the art school, maybe
you saw it, was a flag,
the Imperial Japanese flag.
So fascinating to think
about within that one space
how you have different conflicting ideas
around that particular time
and what it means to
remember World War II.
But I think that that
particular trio of memorials is,
for me, what really struck
me about that memorial
is not only is it a trio of
three different comfort women
on a pedestal but there is a statue
of Kim Hak-sun harmony,
so she's the first Korean
woman who came forward
on August 14, 1991 and what's fascinating
is that she is standing and
she's looking at this trio.
So it raises this interesting
question about time
and also about the
intergenerational reckoning
of this particular history
and that kind of duality
between the young girls and
the older grandmother figure
is something that is repeated
in the bronze girl statue
that I talked about where
behind the bronze girl statue,
you see the mosaic of an elderly woman
and that iconography of the young girl
and the grandmother figure has been used
throughout the social movement,
particularly in South Korea
in terms of the rhetoric
that's used at protests
but also in the actual visual iconography
in terms of images on banners.
- Actually I have a question
for you, if you don't mind.
- Yeah, it's interesting, you
and then I have a comment.
- So I was really interested
also in the memorializations
in the US and I was wondering
if there are locations
in the US and Glendale and New Jersey
invited a kind of,
a different kind of critique
among Korean-Americans
about the role of the US in perpetuating
the system of sexual slavery
like after World War II,
like if that contradiction
of having these memorials
in the US ever came up.
- So the first memorial on
public land on the East Coast
was in Palisades Park, New Jersey
outside of the public library
and in my interviews with
various people involved
in that particular memorial project
and also my attendance
at a dedication ceremony,
people did not express
this kind of criticism
and indictment of the US.
And it did not surprise
me, that of course,
in the dedication ceremony,
that would not be expressed
because part of the possibility
of even having the memorial
on public land meant that
there was coalition building
between Korean Americans and non-Koreans.
But what I found fascinating
about that particular memorial
is the backlash, how a number
of Japanese politicians came
to visit the mayor, Mayor Rotundo
to say what these people are saying,
it's historically false.
Why would this little city get involved
in this particular issue,
we wanna give you all
these gifts of cherry trees
if you will remove the Memorial.
And the mayor famously said,
"You can keep your cherry trees.
"We're keeping our Memorial
and we did our research."
So it's fascinating how
this particular memorial
has taken on this life in this community
because after that particular incident,
then and it was reported and of course,
a number of different Korean newspapers,
that unleashed this
memorial building effort
across the states
where different
Korean-American organizations
were saying, we're gonna
build our own memorial
but interestingly enough,
this kind of critique,
I have not encountered as much during
these public ceremonies
but I find this critique
in cultural work like theater,
that this theater becomes the space
where people are able to talk more
about not just US
complicity in what happened
but also are able to talk
about Korean complicity
and what happened.
So for me, just the
comment and the connection
is it's fascinating that
the comfort women survivors
have become advocates for other women
who are survivors of
gender-based violence.
So two survivors started something
called the Butterfly Fund
in 2013 where when they
would go and testify,
they would collect funds
and different organizations
would raise money so these
women could support victims
of other gender-based violence
and one group of women
they supported were Vietnamese
women who were survivors
of sexual violence
committed by Korean soldiers
during the Vietnam War
and what's fascinating
is that a number of the
comfort women activists
from the main organization
have been going to Vietnam
to collect public testimony
and what's fascinating
is that they're using
some of the same rhetoric
they used to advocate for redress
from the Japanese government
to now advocate for redress
for these Vietnamese women
from the Korean government
and just fascinating to see
the kind of entanglement
between these different histories
of gender-based violence
but ways in which also it's not just
in the structures of violence,
it's also in the different
modes of political organizing.
- Yeah, I remember seeing that exhibit
at the Women's Human
Rights Museum in Seoul
where the last exhibit at the
time was a special exhibit
devoted to this issue and I
thought it was so powerful
that it expanded the
issue and also critiqued
Korean state violence.
- [Mary] I think this is the really...
This is a treat to get to see
you two talk to each other.
So I think this is a great place to end.
Let's give a wonderful round of applause.
(everyone applauds)
(gentle music)